la policía de la capital canadiense se
esfuerza por despejar las calles de
manifestantes el llamado convoy de la
libertad paraliza el centro de Ottawa
desde hace casi un mes el miércoles la
policía les ofreció un ultimátum váyanse
a casa o serán detenidos días más tarde
algunos manifestantes que no han sido
arrestados permanecen en la ciudad
pero lo que no entienden es que estos
camioneros nos abrieron las puertas solo
podemos valernos de su heroísmo por un
momento los camiones no necesitan estar
ahí para que nosotros estemos aquí si
creen en lo que luchamos la libertad
Entonces necesitan venir aquí como
individuos solo tienen que venir aquí y
hacer oír su voz
la policía detuvo más de 40 personas el
sábado pero las autoridades dicen que su
trabajo no ha terminado estamos en esto
se complete la policía ha detenido hasta
ahora más de 150 personas y ha retirado
decenas de camiones cuando las protestas
se ampliaron para incluir a otro
ciudadanos contrarios a la restricciones
el Primer Ministro Justin Trujillo
invoco la ley de emergencias dando a las
autoridades más poderes para sofocar la
revuelta pero la medida ha dividido a
los miembros del parlamento el lunes se
someter a votación para determinar si se
amplían las medidas del gobierno